Hola Andrés qué tal Muy buenas tardes
pues aquí estamos en West Palm Beach en
la carretera que conduce hacia Mara lago
la residencia oficial del expresidente
Donald Trump en Florida y aquí poco a
poco ya se van concentrando decenas de
Seguidores de Donald Trump para expresar
su apoyo y el rechazo a que él tenga que
estar enfrentando la justicia de Estados
Unidos consideran que todo esto forma
parte de un plan orquestado por el
partido demócrata para evitar que se
presente a las próximas elecciones sin
embargo desde la Casa Blanca a pesar de
que el presidente Joe biden ha hecho que
está enfocado en otros asuntos Como por
ejemplo el plan para bajar los precios
sí que ha dicho que está se ha ido
informando puntualmente de lo que ha ido
ocurriendo a través de televisión pero
han habido otras voces críticas por
parte de la bancada azul por parte de la
bancada de los demócratas diciendo que
Donald Trump está enfrentando la
justicia es porque ese es un síntoma de
que nadie está por encima de la ley aquí
las personas los simpatizantes de Donald
Trump lo están esperando llevan dos
horas aproximadamente esperando la
llegada de Donald Trump está previsto
que en poco más de hora y media pueda
llegar el expresidente hasta el
aeropuerto de Palm Beach Y entonces se
va a trasladar hasta hasta la residencia
de Mara lago aquí muchos de sus
simpatizantes están convencidos de que
esto no va a ir a más que incluso va a
salir reforzado de Cara a las próximas
elecciones de 2024 porque según dicen
algunos de ellos este proceso judicial
lo podrá acabar convirtiendo en un
auténtico mártir de aquí de Estados
Unidos al recordar que es la primera vez
que un expresidente está enfrentando a
acusaciones por cargos criminales
Antonio por otro lado se espera que
Trump hable hoy públicamente sobre el
caso desde su mansión en mar al lago
Esta es una afirmación confirmada
Sí realmente Esa es la intención en el
momento el equipo de Donald Trump aquí
en mara lago no ha confirmado que Donald
Trump vaya a hablar finalmente Aunque
muchísimos medios de comunicación de
Estados Unidos apuntan a que sí que
efectivamente el presidente el
expresidente va a hablar por eso muchos
de los simpatizantes aquí en Florida
están pendientes de esa llegada y
también de lo que pueda decir porque
hasta el momento el expresidente aún no
ha hablado acerca de este proceso
judicial en el día de hoy estamos a la
espera de lo que pueda decir pero si
tenemos en cuenta otras declaraciones de
hecho de la semana pasada cuando hizo
referencia a este caso dijo que todo
esto se formaba parte de una caza de
brujas por parte del partido demócrata
Así que aquí en Florida en los
exteriores de Mara lago estamos muy
pendientes de lo que pueda decir a su
llegada aquí en mara la